yeah yeah there your pieces can decide
which squares to control them your
knight only moves into w sorry yeah
meanwhile it looks like white has just
castled queenside in a way the king and
rick on this quest they would have
castled on what's black's king doing in
the corner it's very confusing but
meanwhile the black pawn giving a check
about to promote and it's a big threat
in the air of the bishop giving a check
to the king and uh snapping off the
white rook
and there's also a big threat of
magnus just maneuvering his pieces
around to aid the promotion of the pawn
i'm wondering if white can even give up
his rook now for the black pawn
yes he does it okay he does it so we're
going to see the same game yes
he's going to force magnus to show us
how to check mate now and we will later
see that technique of the knight on
light squares here we go and the bishop
on light squares as well controlling
everything and
okay he did resign he did resign
ah marathon game not even move 100 but
magnus took the win 96 moves a